good morning members
and welcome to this annual meeting today
thursday
[Music]
good morning and welcome to this annual
council meeting today thursday the 20th
of may
2021 my name is councillor mark
hurd and i am the chairman of district
council
there are a few housekeeping issues to
run through
the setup of this meeting has been
designed to mitigate for covid
and we ask members to work to the
protocols agreed at the council meeting
on the 29th
of april 2021 in the interest
of member and officer safety
this meeting will be streamed live and
recorded
and by being present in the meeting
reported members officers during each
item please hold up the indicator on the
desk in front of you
to indicate if you wish to speak i will
then invite you at the appropriate time
members this process this morning will
obviously be different
and for some items i may invite each
member to speak in turn therefore i
would encourage all members
to keep your contributions as clear and
concise
as possible please when invited to speak
please remain seated
remove your mask put on your visor
and speak clearly when speaking and
referring to the agenda papers
please ensure you reference a page or
paragraph number
thank you very much
i move on now to agenda item
two which is the election of chairman
for
this municipal year and i call for
nominations
for chairman of the council for this
year
councillor none
yes good morning uh chairman i'd like to
nominate you to continue
uh in the position again
[Music]
thank you very much uh is there is there
a second for that
councillor maze thank you very much are
there any other nominations
are there any other nominations i will
take these
in turn then
and we will go to the votes
could i ask for those in favor of
myself to please show
because
[Music]
a recorded vote is that seconded
it is not seconded so can i have a show
and please
one two three four are you able to do
this time
thank you
[Music]
thank you
once
counselor
[Music]
[Music]
councillor
[Music]
those against these
[Music]
[Music]
uh that's a hole
okay thank you
any extensions
in that case that is included
thank you members thank you members for
your confidence
i now move to a vote for the election
of the vice chairman of the council
do i have uh from the chair i would like
to nominate
councillor carly mates
second is by councillor stan thank you
are there any other nominations
no eliminations in that case
yes indeed i'm reminded that i have to
in order that i can do this legally i
have to make the declaration of
acceptance
so i mark steven heard having been
elected to the office of chairman of the
council of the district of malden
declared that i will take that office
upon myself
and i will duly and faithfully fulfill
the duties of it
according to the best of my judgment and
ability
i undertake to observe the code as to
the conduct
which is expected of members of malden
district council i will sign that now
[Music]
i now move to the election of the vice
chairman of the council
and from the chair i will nominate
councillor carly mayes
is that seconded councillor no thank you
very much
are there any other nominations
[Music]
in that case can we take a vote on that
please
those in favor
district council congratulations uh i'll
now
ask her to complete the declaration of
acceptance of office
i'm carly mayes having been elected to
the office the vice chairman of the
council of the
[Music]
which
thank you very much
which is apologies for absence please
[Music]
thank you very much agenda item number
seven
declarations of interest to disclose the
existence and nature of any disclosable
pecunic interests
other peculiar interests or
non-pecuniary interests
relating to items of business on the
agenda having regard to paragraphs
six to eight inclusive
members are reminded that they are also
required to disclose
any such interests as soon as they
become aware that the need arise
throughout the meeting any declarations
of
interest countless schemes
so i just wanted to clarify something
you just said you said paragraph 6
12. i just wanted to make sure
okay that is noted thank you very much
[Music]
i'm sorry
no thank you very much agenda item
eight minutes of the meeting of the
council on the 18th of march it is
recommended that the minutes of the
meeting
held on the 18th of march 2021
found on pages 7 to 20 are approved
as for true and accurate records
i so do i have
[Music]
thank you can i take it members that you
were very notified
thank you very much agenda item nine
minutes
of the council 29th of april 2021
is recommended that the minutes of the
extraordinary meeting
held on the 29th of april 2021
and found on pages 21 to 26 are approved
as a true and accurate record
thank you very much agenda item 10
public questions there are none
number 11 general 11 chairman's
announcement
i have none other than to thank you for
your presence
and indeed to them to the staff who have
set up this meeting this morning i'll
just thank them
again now item 12 the minute book
and we move to this minute
uh this is the performance governance
and audit
from the 24th of march 2021 they're
downloading ages 27 to 32.
councillor councillors
on the 24th of march 2021
these are found on pages 27-32
and i've proposed their reception and
adoption
thank you is that secondary councillor
thank you very much if any member wishes
to raise any matter of accuracy
then please indicate that you wish to
speak
now take it that we agree those five
cents agree
thank you very much agenda item 13
minutes of meetings of the council this
is to note
that since the last meeting of the
council and up until
wednesday the 12th of may 2021
the committees listed have met and to
receive
any questions in accordance with council
and committee procedure
rule 6-2 if any member wishes to raise a
question
in relation to the minutes of this
meeting please make this known
i have no members
please can you confirm you're happy to
know these means
is that everybody's happy thank you very
much
agenda item 14 notice of
motion in accordance with notice duly
given under procedure rule four
councillor helm has proposed three
motions which are set out
on page three of the agenda pack
counselor helen could you please read
out your motions
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you thank you councillor helm
uh councillor fluka you have seconded
this motion do you wish to add or say
anything
um
thank you very much do i have any
members
who wish to speak on this matter
councillor
thank you chairman uh it's quite
interesting in terms of
justification for bringing this motion
to the council
and for these changes uh he
he's told us just now that he's not raw
emotion
to this council in 10 years so it's
interesting and in those 10 years
he was a member of the previous
administration
therefore if these motions were
important at that time
they should have been included so
therefore
i do not understand why these need to be
considered
now and therefore
well thank you very much councillor uh
big chairman um
[Music]
um so i think that you know it's great
that the
leaders should confirm um the first
motions
so i think that the leader has the
opportunity to answer a question
i think where i am i think the second
part of the motion is
i don't know any leader any person
boris johnson problems that he's had
he's had to defer to chief medicalisers
and many
uh motion three
you can ask you can ask the leader of
the council at any time a question
so i can't see why we want to take up
valuable council time
and to ask a question when a question
can be asked and an answer given so
uh
thank you um i'd just like to ask our
counselor
um help if he actually knows what the
word filibustering means
um i'm actually in favor because i don't
think that's such a bad thing is a bad
question you can't really have a bad
question
we don't talk enough on this council we
don't debate enough on this council
this council isn't actually run by the
councillors
it's run by insidious officers so
whilst i am in favour of some of the
emotions
so that each one of them is voted on
individually
because i do believe that the
officers should be able to speak
[Music]
[Music]
thank you sir um i'll go to uh
councillor channel
[Music]
um
[Music]
this authority has gone on and is a
helpful way actually to help a leader
then compose the full response if not
able to learn in the meeting
so emotions are relatively um sound in
their
objects thank you thank you very much
councillor thompson
oh thank you
[Music]
thank you councillor schemes uh thank
you chair
um two things i think this uh is
this motion is just a sort of political
maneuvering and i don't
i will be supporting it i've also got a
problem with some of the council and
morris said he described the cats was
run by
insidious officers i just think that's
unfair
and uncalled for and i would ask
for him to withdraw it but i know that
he won't but um i just want to say that
i have a lot of respect for the officers
we have here
who do work incredibly hard thank you
can i come back to that voice chair
i will allow you to come back yes thank
you
and whilst we do have some good officers
we also
have a lot of officers that are acting
insidiously
incorruptly and i will say that and i'll
continue to say that
i have proof
[Music]
[Music]
are you preparing to withdraw your
remark about the staff not
on your nelly fella okay thank you very
much
okay thank you um hopefully you can hear
me and i would like to say
i find that um so offensive because the
officers
are not in a position to reply debate is
where somebody can to and throw now that
accusation that has been made
um whether you feel it's your right
[Applause]
uh
that we do get written responses from
the leader
if that is necessary however the motion
states
that the leader does not defer so that
bear this in mind is that just recently
the council adopted values those values
are the thing that should guide us all
and when i hear
comments that do not abide brothers
then that is something that we all need
to look at ourselves
so we need to ensure that all of us are
abiding by the values that are now
set for both officers and members
and part of that is we may
[Music]
um
and whether it is
is
[Music]
um
[Music]
so insofar as the motions
want something on the agenda are all
agendas
for all pounds in fact that is changing
little
m in relation to no
[Music]
actually physically changes the
constitution other
in relation to the animal meeting
[Music]
thank you very much
i don't really understand the logic
behind motion two
um if we found
aren't we because none of us the leader
or any
member here can be an expert technically
in every subject
but we do have technical experts with
the officers
and surely that's why they're employed
and why they attend meetings
otherwise what's the purpose of them
being here at all
so i i wouldn't uh profess
in any shape or form to know uh things
about
everything and i would defer to an
officer to give me technical support
so for that reason i certainly can't
support motion
um
myself
um
the questions
issues
wish to ask questions
found himself
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
um
[Music]
for example
vote now unless any other member who
hasn't previously spoke and wishes to
speak
you can let me speak mark
okay so can i ask for those members who
are who wish to vote in favor
of these or first of all um
councillor morris did ask for an
amendment
um is that seconded
asked for an amendment to these motions
is that seconded
as it is an amendment uh i'll i'll hear
what you've got to say councillor morris
what does your remains um firstly i'd
like to just say that um
isn't it funny and ironic how counselor
uh in his time as labour never
i believe that some of these um
points uh the first and third point are
i do have merit
but i will be against the seconds the
second part of the motion
so i would i would uh ask
that we vote on each one separately
um and thank you council for second in
that
i didn't hear what you said
yes
[Laughter]
okay
[Laughter]
oh
those in favor right counselor key
yes
yes
[Laughter]
is
[Laughter]
uh
[Laughter]
against
[Music]
[Music]
yes
[Music]
[Applause]
again
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
guys
is
[Laughter]
again
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
against
we have the royal game please uh
[Laughter]
[Music]
council morris
county against that's the signal
the gates that's the steam very good
[Music]
thank you that has uh failed then we
move on to
agenda item 15 questions in accordance
with procedure
6 2 of which notice has been given i can
confirm that we move on to
agenda item 16 leaders and competition
of political groups
and these have been in circulated today
pack pages three and four
the recommendations are set out in this
report as follows that the council
considers ratification of the lisa's
council but in the event that the
council does not confirm the leader
designate to
elect the leader of the council and
three that the council
elects the deputy leader of the council
i move the recommendation which is set
out
in the report that the council considers
ratification of the leader designate
councillor wendy stamp as leader of the
council
is that seconded councillor mays
thank you very much i will now take a
vote on that or are you
happy to agree that by a cent
thank you very much we move on now to
the election of a uh the deputy leader
designate
and i move that the council considers
ratification
of the leader the deputy leader
designate councillor
stephen nunn as deputy leader of the
council
is that seconded
[Laughter]
m
[ __ ]
confirmation of the appointment
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
ah
[Laughter]
that member nominations
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
uh
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
uh
[Laughter]
uh
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Music]
item 18 which is the adjournment
of this meeting so i intend
to adjourn this meeting at 10 48
to allow the following meetings of the
council
to take place that is performance
[Laughter]
governance
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
so
mr dodson could you please call out
those members
who will be sitting on the performance
governance and audit committee
yes thank you
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
in that case i declare
that councillor stilts is appointed as
chairman
of performance governance and audit
committee and i will now
hand over to her as chairman of that
committee
thank you mr chairman um i would like to
call for nominations for vice chair
of the performance governance and audit
[Music]
um
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
those against please show
those abstaining
council of morley councillor durham
councillor thompson
in that case i declare that
councillor richard siddall is appointed
as chairman of the
of the strategy and resources committee
and i now
hand over to him as chairman thank you
very much
for watching
um
for that council
[Laughter]
uh
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
councillor helen
thank you i will now call for
nominations of chairman of overview
and scrutiny councillor mates uh i would
like to nominate councillor vanessa bell
vanessa bell is that seconded
thank you very much
[Music]
are there any other nominations council
appeal
is that seconded on that commitment
in that case
vanessa bell being chairman of oakley
and scrutiny please
show council of passenger councillor
bell council of steen's council of males
those against councillor hell
i therefore declare that councillors
there
uh is hereby appointed as chairman of
that committee
and our hand over to her thank you mr
chairman
i would
thank you any other nominations
in that case council bell i presume
you're trying to declare
okay mr chairman i declared waiting
special needs libraries
thank you for that and the meeting will
be closed at 10 59
special meeting of the jsc leader
before we move on can i ask mr quelch
and the directors for a procedural
matter
and i'm a little bit confused whether
councillor bill
and bill could have seconded councillor
durham's proposal
and licensing because she doesn't sit on
that committee
today thank you thank you for that but i
just need to make sure that the process
has been followed so then it didn't come
back
that the process hasn't been followed so
mr clutch and the director said i have
confirmation
that that previous nomination and
licensing was does it do to the rules
please
leave your correct if um
so where does that leave us please
because i know the motion failed or the
recommendation
[Music]
thank you thank you we'll move on now
to special meeting of the joint
standards committee
mr dawson could i have the names please
yes councillor passenger
councillor mays councillor knight
thank you i i call for nominations for
chairman of the joint standards
committee
um councilman um i'd like to propose
councillor mark bassinger
is that secondary councilman thank you
very much
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you mr chairman uh i would like to
call for nominations the vice chair of
the joint science committee and from the
chair i would like to propose
are there any other nominations is that
seconded first of all oh sorry
councillor mays thank you very much uh
any other nominations
there are no chairman there i
counseled as vice chair of the joint
standards committee
and uh i closed the joint standards
committee meeting
i closed the meeting
thank you closed uh yes cancer schemes
yes uh i've had a
message from somebody saying that
there's a problem with the sound quality
uh i'm just hoping that that might be
addressed thank you
i would endear just to uh to make sure
that i'm uh
heard both in name and nature
with the member of the public um
following online
child hearing thank you very much
hopefully our it staff will be looking
at that
[Music]
thank you very much thank you
i'm going to move on now to a special
meeting of the investigation
and disciplinary committee mr dawson
could i have the names please
counselor councillor heard
councillor stan stevens
councillor swain councillor mrs hull
councillor mrs thompson councillor miss
white
councillor boyce and councillor jarvis
thank you i now call on nominations for
chairman
of this committee do i have any
proposals
councillor stan and i'd like to propose
a councillor
vanessa bear
thank you very much are there any other
nominations
i'd like to expose cancer china
is
this is the special meeting of the
investigation and disciplinary committee
sorry that's not correct so you just
read it
the name has
does not seem to be on the agenda it's
not
great
sorry sorry
[Music]
mr dobson i apologize i i've read out
as as councillor said that the list of
the panel
not the committee if i can confirm
that the members of the investigating
and disciplinary committee
councillor civil councillor nunn
councillor mrs chana councillor hughner
and councillor helen
thank you very much so from those five
five
members i now call for nominations of
chairman of that committee do i have any
nominations
cancer cougar boys
nomination are there any other
nominations counselors
okay
myself
counselor who counselor howl counselor
channel
over against
those abstaining
i have one in that case
uh i declare that uh councillor channel
becomes chairman of the uh
thank you very much
[Applause]
vice chancellor
[Applause]
[Music]
is
[Music]
bruce hoover be the vice chairman of the
investigation
and its finning committee for this
currently this year
there'll be no further business journal
i quote
thank you thank you very much
um the
investor i don't have that on my papers
so uh investigation and disciplinary
[Music]
panels
the special meeting of the planning
committee
district district planning committee yes
uh could i have the names please mr
dodson
sharing that's all members of the
council right okay
in that case i um i call
for
okay i'm told that that is uh except
council of cluca so therefore
i call for nominations for chairman of
this
committee councillor mate um
thank you very much are there any other
nominations
there are none can we agree that my sent
members
agree thank you very much
uh so as the newly elected chairman i
now
call for uh nominations
thank you very
[Applause]
declare much uh accountant is appointed
as vice chairman and i close this
meeting at 11
11. the next is a
special meeting of the central planning
committee please might have the names mr
dalton
councillor
[Music]
councillor edwards manchester swain
council steele councillor heisner
councillor lawrence thank you i now call
for nominations
to the chairman of the central planning
committee
for the municipal year of many to may
2022
houses
nominations council morris uh yes sir
i'd just like to ask um
uh can we exclude pencil morris on this
because he's far too good-looking
becomes chairman of the central planning
committee
thank you
are there any other nominations
sorry about that is to ignore the chair
[Music]
um
[Music]
thank you council i now adverts
on to the northwest planning committee
northwestern area planning committee
so i have the names please mr dodson
councillor
councillor stevens answered
[Music]
thank you i will now call for
nominations to
chairman of the north west
area planning committee for the
municipal year
to may 22. is there any nominations
councillor fleming
councillor thompson has been nominated
is that seconded
seconded by council of keys are we able
to agree that by ascent members
uh in that case i declare uh that
uh councilman thompson is uh therefore
[Music]
[Music]
yes
[Music]
sure
thank you 11 15. i have that
i now move to a special meeting of the
southeast area planning could i have the
names please mr johnson
councillor passenger councillor neal
councillor bell councillor steves
councillor stamp councillor mrs chandler
councillor mrs hull councillor boyce
anthony and councillor hellmuth
thank you i will now call for
nominations to chairman
of the south east area family committee
councillor stan um i'd like to propose
councillor bill
is yes about councillors
thank you are there any other
nominations
councillor channel councillor this is
[Music]
please show that's sir
councillor messenger councillor bell
councillor schemes council appeal
councillor staff those against
the council of councillor china
[Music]
that has failed then i therefore declare
that councillor vanessa bell
is hereby appointed as chairman of south
east
[Music]
it is by councillor
[Music]
are there any other nominations for the
vice chair
cancer channel yes
so i believe
[Music]
[Music]
thank you so much
yes
[Music]
could i ask members to be mindful of
the opposing restrictions and uh please
to be careful
uh the title counselor
from a who've asked me to member
you the youtube sounds not working
properly but it's been through german
members of the public
[Music]
okay we'll look at that through the
fight so
could i have at half past
11 please thank you
various comments
thank you mayors i've had various
comments about the sound quality
uh i'm taking instruction and
as a as i'm constantly speaking
uh i and this is a workplace
not to wear it
so uh members we will now resume the
business of the union council
[Music]
now that we have confirmed the
chairman's appointments
we need to return to a general item 17
which is the appointment of members of
committees of the council
to confirm membership of the
appointments board
yes that's right
if the leader of the council mrs chan
as leader of the opposition i believe
that we now need an additional
nomination from the conservative
group this is for the appointment of the
appointments yes
very well
thank you
[Music]
deputy the chairman or vice chairman of
the strategy and resources
and performance governance and audit
committees
councillor w health and councillor jane
fleming do i have a second
thank you very much i therefore declare
that
agenda item 20 is the appointment of
representatives to local government
and outside bodies and therefore we move
to this agenda item which is found in
your supplementary pack
pages 13 to 22.
before i call on the leader to introduce
this item
please note that under recommend
recommendation two
representatives for the following
outside body
has yet to be agreed that is the stone
mary's aerodrome consultative
committee leader please introduce the
report
yeah thank you chairman members
and this the purpose of this report is
to consider the appointments and
representatives to serve
on the local government and outside
bodies for the municipal year
to may 2022 the recommendations little
one
is that the appointment of
representatives to local government and
outside bodies as detailed in appendix
one
be agreed for the remainder of the
municipal year little two
that the representatives are not
approved and that represents are not
approved and those highlighted in
section 3.51
members to appoint these outside body
seats and that is as chairman just said
the stone mar is aerodrome consultative
committee
and we will go back to that one and
three that the members appoint the
representatives to local governments and
outside bodies are responsible for
sharing minutes
of meetings attended be stored centrally
on the malden gov library
as for the details in section 3.6
and do i have a second uh of those thank
you
councillor mays thank you so members um
i think we can agree
listen one and two has been okay is that
all right number five
and then we'll just do um little two we
agree that by ascend members
thank you um so members we have a
only one but i don't actually like to
thank um
the members of the opposition leader and
the
dags for all the hard work that has gone
in
to agree all these committees and
outside bodies and working groups and
the compromise
from the independent group as well and
for
for actually accommodating some of the
difficult choices and decisions but
congratulate
councillor helm and cancer channel and
all our groups and members
are coming to this to say there's only
one that we've got to
take a vote on is is admirable and thank
you for the collateral
collaborative working so moving on
members
and i would like to uh if we all turn to
the page we've got
two nominations um i'd like to propose
that cancer stephen nunn and chancellor
kevin kevin lagan
are our representatives on the stone
mary's aerodrome consultative committee
can i have a secondary
counselor councillor maze do i have a
alternative please cancel china
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you councillor channel is that
seconded
councillor beal
uh i will take uh i will take then uh
the first proposal which is councillor
nun
and councillor lagan as being those
representatives
um could i ask please to for you to show
uh
if you are in favor of councillor none
and councillor lagan please hold up your
indicators
uh so one two three four five six
seven eight nine ten eleven twelve
thirteen 14.
1 2 3 4 5
6 7 8 9 10 11
12 13 14 15
16 goes against
[Music]
one two three four five six seven
eight nine nine
okay that that is uh that is agreed then
councillor nunn and councillor lagan
will be those
uh representatives thank you members
we move on now to agenda item 21
the appointment of members to set on
working groups
these were found in supplementary pack
pages 23
to 26 and i now call on the leader
to present the report leader
thank you chairman um this purpose of
the report is to appoint members to
serve on the working groups of the
council for the municipal year to may
2022
the recommendations are that members
approved the nominations provided for
the working groups in appendix one
that the nominations are not that where
nominations are not approved members
appoint these
working seats one group seats i've just
put members please note 3.2 of the
report
just in case members haven't read it uh
thoroughly
the following groups have been removed
from the list the asset management
working group this work has been picked
up elsewhere in commercial activity the
community the still community
infrastructure live
at levy working group which we worked so
hard to get on
uh has been substand into the planning
policy working group and has been
removed without meeting i believe
and the moulding market member task and
finish working group
the modern market incorporated into
covert 19 reset and recovery
and i would like to propose that we
agree all the recommendations on the
working groups
by um by sending on mass do i have a
second to please
councillor mates
[Music]
members can we agree that by ascent
thank you very much agenda item 22
which is the annual report of the
overview and scrutiny committee
this is found on pages 33-36
i will now call on councillor vanessa
bell to present the report
councillor bell thank you
and to um approval of future
arrangements
so the regulation is
thank you councillor bell do i have a
secondary councillor maze
thank you question councillor morris
yeah um can i just have ignorant
um i do believe that 3.52
all right thank you very much members uh
i'm going to
uh so i have a second i'm going to take
that to the vote can we agree that
recommendation by ascent
thank you very much agenda item 23
business by reason of
special circumstance considered by the
chairman to be urgent
there is none i now move to
agenda item 24 which is the exclusion of
the press
and public and therefore i move that the
council resolves
that under section 100 a 4
of the local government acts 1972 the
public be excluded from the meeting for
the following item of business on the
grounds
that it involves the likely disclosure
of exempt
information as defined in paragraph 3
of part 1 of schedule 12a to the act
and that this satisfies the public
interest
test iso move is that seconded
councillor maze thank you very much
and so members of the public
uh and press um i have to say thank you
for your time
here uh and we will now be um
closing the live stream